[Música]
cuando yo era pequeña
mis recuerdos quedaban grabados en fotos
de papel
y esas fotos de papel las almacenamos en
un álbum
al usar unos libros para los que no
saben
eran unos modos en algunos libros como
por dos viejos
también había de otros tamaños
pero resulta que sus álbumes eran el
tesoro más preciado que tenía una
familia o por lo menos la mía
que ha guardado muy bien y sus álbumes
nuestros rostros
nuestras vivencias y nuestros momentos
más importantes
ahora viene una pregunta como hacía a
alguien externo a mi hogar a mi familia
oa mi casa para acceder a ese alto
muy simple primero que todas esas
personas tenían que llegar a mi casa yo
no obvio tenía que pararse en la puerta
y tenía que timbre
luego de eso mi papá y mi mamá se asoman
tienes
después de ver quién era si esa persona
era bienvenida
mi mamá bajaba abría la puerta y hacía
seguir a esta persona al pasillo hasta
ahí
dependiendo de la visita o no y de la
comodidad y puede decir hasta el buen
humor de mi mamá o de mi papá esa visita
se pasaba a la sala
y estando en la sala
pues a veces mi papá le podría decir
porque no te sentás
y la persona
después de una plática que iba y venía y
venía mi mamá decía esta frase hermosa
venga le traigo un juguito
y de trayecto
cuando ya esta persona se tomaba el cubo
y que uno suponía que había una
conversación muy agradable y muy plácida
venía la frase del millón
venga le muestro el álbum de la niña
tienes alguna vía una foto que era
importantísimo se acuerda de la foto en
la bañera
que todos salíamos chateando y felices
fueron unos tantos a veces no tanto
porque el agua estaba muy fría o no sé
pero salíamos desnudos y sin tapujos y
si usted me escuchó con atención antes
de mi mamá lanzar la frase script de 20
muestro el alma de mi hija que era lo
más sagrado que mi mamá tenía mi mamá
hizo 8 filtros primero
la persona tuvo que pasar ocho pasos
desde que llegué a mi casa hasta que se
sentó para que pudiera escuchar la frase
tan anhelada 20 muestro el álbum
esos álbumes de papel ya no existen
el mundo cambió
llegó internet
[Música]
y con interno llega un poder bellísimo y
es el poder de la conectividad
usted puede hablar con una gran amistad
que tiene al otro lado del mundo con un
solo clic
y además de que puede hablar con una
persona que está al otro lado del mundo
usted puede presenciar eventos donde
usted en cuerpo presente no puede estar
puede ver el nacimiento de un hijo
puede asistir a la graduación de un
sobrino super querido
además puede estar en el matrimonio de
su mejor amigo o de su mejor amiga
e internet nos permite hacer esto 24
horas al día 7 días a la semana 365 días
es algo maravilloso
pero esa misma facilidad y esa misma
inmediatez personalmente me asusta
muchísimo
porque por esa misma facilidad nos
estamos llevando por delante
a los seres más vulnerables que tenemos
en nuestro planeta
qué son nuestros niños niñas y
adolescentes
tenemos tanta necesidad
de exponernos que no estamos poniendo
sentido común a la hora de exponer a
nuestros menor
cada vez
y usted publica o usted sube la foto de
su hijo o de su hija usted pierde el
control automático de esa fotografía
y lo más complejo es que en todos los
estudios de investigaciones que ha hecho
a través de los años la gran cantidad de
publicaciones de estos chiquitines
responden más al ego y al narcisismo del
papá y de la mamá
porque es que yo no veo a un niño de 2
años diciéndole mamá pública me en
facebook
bbc y me está diciendo la mamá qué pasa
que no salgo en instagram
esto responde más a mi necesidad de
exponer
y perdemos de vista que esa fotografía o
esa publicación o ese vídeo puede ser el
cebo o el postre de un depredador sexual
en línea esta esfera
lastimosamente estudios demuestran
que el 1 por ciento de toda población
tiende
a la pedofilia y a la pederastia el 1
que usted vive en un país es colombia
que tiene aproximadamente 48 millones de
colombianos qué significa eso que en
este país mal contados existen 480 mil
pedófilos y pederastas que andan por ahí
pero día 24 y lo más triste aberrante y
preocupante de esto es que las
tecnologías mal utilizadas lo que
hicieron fue facilitar el acercamiento
de estos depredadores a nuestros niños
y aquí es cuando ocurre el delito de
pornografía
infantil
el que tome fotos field grave produzca
almacene solicite divulguen compre venda
port o sea ofrezca transmita o exhiba
por cualquier medio ya sea para uso
personal o intercambio representación de
personas menores de 18 años en actos
sexuales está incurriendo en el delito
de pornografía infantil
los expertos han querido cambiar la
terminología porque se cree que el
término pornografía minimiza del hecho
por lo tanto quieren pasarlo a material
de explotación sexual infantil pero
usted utilizará en toda esta charla la
tema el tema perdón de pornografía
infantil porque es como está verificado
en nuestro código p
lastimosamente usted vive en uno de los
países que más pornografía infantil
produce en toda américa latina
en lo transcurrido del presente año del
2019 17.000 niños han sido violentados
sexualmente causa 17.000 y dos niños
están muriendo diarios por esa causa
usted sabe cuál es la cifra de 17.000
para que tenga una idea 17.000 es la
cantidad de niños que hay actualmente
inscritos en preescolar aquí en cali
entre el sector privado y público es
como si a cada uno de esos chicos que
llevamos al jardín un abusador a un
depredador sexual lo hubiera violentado
el pasado 19 de octubre está en la
página de pornografía infantil más
grande en toda la historia se llamaba
welcome to vídeo tenían 8 terabytes de
información esto quiere decir más de
250.000 vídeos y más de 40.000 fotos de
niños niñas y preadolescentes se
capturan 338 pedófilos a nivel mundial
eran los que lideraban la comunidad de
pederasta y pedofilia y tenían sus
actuales en 58 países pero los
territorios que tenían priorizados eran
eeuu corea del sur y reino unido- el año
pasado fueran bloqueadas a nivel mundial
78 mil 559 páginas
y lo complejo del asunto es que cada
página de estas tiene visitas diaria de
100 mil clics
viajes
y las ganancias que da esta industria
más de 5 millones de dólares al mes
entre enero y abril de este año en este
país se han bloqueado 727 páginas
ahora usted se preguntará si camina
y ese material de donde lo consigue de
donde aparecen toda esa cantidad de
fotos
existen tres formas
la primera es el sexting
es la emisión o producción de
fotografías con alto contenido sexual
pero el sexting tiene una particularidad
y es que el sexting es voluntario y en
más de un 90% lo producimos las mujeres
el hombre pide que nos desnudamos usted
produce el material y ellos son
simplemente los que nos incitan a la
acción
lastimosamente cuando ya tenemos el
sexting es estando en edades a partir de
los 8 años
tenemos casos de sexo después de que
pasamos de sexting pasamos a las
extorsiones es cuando ya la de la foto o
el vídeo se produjo y la persona que
tiene el material lo utiliza en su
contra o encuentra el menor o te sigues
desnudando para mí o muestro y mando la
foto se la manda tu papá se la manda a
tu papá a tu mamá
la suba a la redes y el niño
automáticamente que hace el susto
sigue produciendo el material y por
último tenemos para mí el más aterrador
es el grooming que son los adultos que
se hacen pasar por niños en internet
no hay un perfil defecto para un grupo y
eso es lo que lo hace tan peligroso aquí
pueden haber entre nosotros porque
tenemos casos de padres de familia con
hijos lo único que podemos descifrar es
que en la gran mayoría más del 90% los
grooming son hombres y el restante son
mujeres además se encuentran en un 35
por ciento en el círculo familiar en el
primero del menor
el otro 45% lo conoce mi hijo y sólo el
10% es aleatorio sólo el 10% es al azar
son seres extremadamente pacientes
pueden estar detrás de un menor para una
sola foto entre 12 a 16 meses
y después de que ya consiguen la
confianza del menor tras haber hecho una
gran ingeniería social perfilando los
perfiles de sus víctimas le cuesta sólo
12 minutos hacer que mi hijo se quite la
ropa solo 12 minutos
pueden mantener hasta 200 conversaciones
al mismo tiempo y sus horarios
preferidos de acción son entre las 2 de
la tarde y las 7 de la noche y entre las
11 de la noche y las 4 de la mañana en
la primera franja usted dónde está
pero su hijo a qué hora llega
y en la segunda franja usted donde está
porque trabajo todo el día
dormido pero nuestros chicos que hacen
pone
organizaciones mundiales informan
y uno de cuatro niños va a ser abusado o
violentado sexualmente antes de que
cumpla los 18 años de edad
y sólo uno de cada nueve nos va a contar
el resto o sea los otros nueve no lo van
a s
pero recuerda la cifra que yo le
mencioné de los 17.000 menores abusados
sexualmente esto es el 11%
estos son los casos que sabemos
pero como le parece que el universo
papal alberga a más de 120 mil menores
que en este instante están siendo
abusados o violentados sexualmente y no
tenemos ni idea
porque no sabemos por lo tanto va a ser
muy difícil ayudar
de pronto usted en este momento estará
muy asustado o asustado y preocupado por
las cifras que la cavada y debería estar
pero tengo casos de éxito bellísimos
llevo más de siete años dio más de
veinte trabajando con niños niñas y
adolescentes en situación de
vulnerabilidad pero llevo alrededor de
siete años trabajando el tema de ética y
entornos digitales positivos
y en estos 8 años en todas las
instituciones educativas y comunidades
que ha intervenido me encontrado con
casos visiones
de niños y niñas que te dicen sabes que
profe yo no me voy a tomar esa foto
niños y niñas que te dicen no profe
prestigio como voy a mandar esa foto mía
behring a cómo se te ocurre
eso no se hace
niños y niñas que tienen la capacidad de
decir no
y de pararse y decir no lo voy a hacer y
cuando empecé a indagar cuál era la
diferencia entre ese niño y esa niña que
decía no tenía el control y entre ese
niño y esa niña que lastimosamente
enviaba la fotografía era su muralla de
contención o sea su familia
y cuando me refiero a muralla de
contención y familia no me refiero a que
tienen que haber 50 personas por encima
del niñito cuidándolos no
con un solo adulto uno solo
con una abuela querendona con un padre
presente con una madre amorosa con un
hermano protector con un tío estricto
pero poniendo normas y reglas desde el
amor con ese solo adulto cuidado podemos
hacer el milagro para este chico
para terminar
siempre que usted vaya a subir
la fotografía de su hijo o de su hija
hágase esta pregunta
qué pasa si no es como la foto
la respuesta en 99.9 de la pc para ser
nada
por lo tanto no la suma
y si en efecto usted cree que
definitivamente esa foto o ese vídeo
debe compartirse de alguna sugerencia
muy respetuoso por favor envía la foto
por correo electrónico y escoja las
personas que usted quiere que tengan
esta fotografía
o si no cree un grupo de whatsapp y en
ese grupo envié la fotografía y haga la
aclaración cuando envié la foto no deseo
que esta foto sea difundida es sólo para
esto no le garantizo que la foto no se
vaya
no porque usted ya perdió el control
sobre ella no podemos hacer los pastos
mentales pero por lo menos vamos a
mitigar el hecho y por favor jamás
jamás
nunca
suba fotografías de su hija donde
aparezcan solos nunca hagáis
siempre publique fotos o comparta fotos
donde el niño o la niña salgan
acompañados por adultos cuidados porque
eso de una u otra manera está demostrado
científicamente que pone freno al
depredador
perdón
de pronto usted después de escucharme
pensara
el monstruo digital en el armario es la
pornografía infantil
o el material de abuso sexual de niños
niñas y adolescentes pues como le parece
que no
el verdadero monstruo digital
es que usted como adulto cuidador piense
este monstruo no va a llegar a su casa
porque usted piense que eso le pasa a
otro y no a mí muchísimas
[Aplausos]